こんにちははじめ施設をです最近
運がないあのたぶんみなさんの想像している以上に僕は裏でとても
ねえ皆さんが想像している以上に僕は裏で舌すごい積雲が悪いんですよね今年は厄年と
いうこともあっていろいろあったんですけど
年末がいやまぁ平和に行きたいなということで運勢を変えるためには
仮眠前に祈るしかないこれしかないと僕は思っておりますもうなんでもいいんです南
鴨居のれで問題があればもう僕は良いのとき体力で今日の企画はこちらに今神社がある
んですけどもこちら a 高杉神社という神社でございますだよ第月に恋愛 d に
今年も運が悪いんで神社で前回お参りすると運勢は良くなるのかという検証をして
いこうと思い
マーサーカっぽい曲ですね結局はそういうねやっぱ気持ちの問題なんでは前回祈った
ことによる効力というより旋回祈った俺すげーみたいなその自分に言い聞かせで自己姉
の利上げによって自分の運気を上げていくというポテンシャルの問題統合的に含めてを
前に旋回することによってどういう効果があるかちょっと検証していきたいとおもい
ます
ボスあのもちろん冷やかしに行ってるわけでなく
9月でありますから神社のお参りの方法を確実にやっていきますはその一鳥居をくぐる
なので旋回やるときは僕とリー予選がいい増幅しなきゃなりません
鳥居をくぐるときは直前で火力一例しますとレイナードの3つを言って主要歩いちゃ
ダメなんだ神社の道を歩くときは端っこ道の端っこ歩かないとダメみたいです長は神様
が通るらしいの
で市で課金ガチが抑え線に紅範囲に拍手市兵衛例1例で戻ると法橋9件一通りのやり方
は分かったんでこのマニュアルどおりハンピげな動きをちゃんとやるんですけど
ちょっと金の問題がやべぇた旋回
お参りしていこうと思いますって良い子
b 6 e
はいん
リコーリコールとは根太に俺の活力が故障したということ
故障ってがこそしてたってことを学ばず点検に行かなきゃいけなくなったみたいです
そこだ
ああああああ
はいというわけでようやく50回行きました1回1回のお前リオ結構真剣に気持ち込め
てやってるんで50回でも相当疲れました
もうちょい頑張ってみます
[音楽]
ん
1回ぐらい
現象ですかありがとうございます
はいというわけでとりあえず100歳を前にしました
あのひとつ入っていいですか
終わらないの動作自体はシンプルなので適当によると思いますがあるんですけども僕つ
の1回ずつ本気でお願いしながらやってるんで時間がかかるんですよすいませんたぶん
このペースでやっていると一日だと終わらないので空いてる時間を見つけて何日かかけ
てちゃんと旋回お前しようと思いますとりあえず今日は100回で終わっておき
ましょうでは
[音楽]
ana
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
bejean
えっ
[音楽]
た
tan
はいというわけで300回終わりました
暗いなぁまだまだ100回頑張っていこうと思います
5倍粥100回分です入っていきます
[音楽]
てっちゃん
はぁ
昇るの50回いきます
400回終わりました
まだ多分太陽は沈むのでもうちょっと時間があるので今日でも500回入っちゃい
ましょう
あと100回やります
[音楽]
というわけで打ち込ん奴は終わりました時々100回ほんと全然いけるんですけど
200回となると頭痛という形分
no 動かすから頭を動かすから返事するみたいになってきっとも苦しかったで
折り返しです後500回頑張っていこうと思いますではお客様です
今から200回やって700回分のを前に行ってこういうと思いますでは500円玉
200名
自分ですではいい
[音楽]
なかったもおかしくなりそうなんですけど今日はもう100回やって700回まで
行こうと思いますってよああ
[音楽]
[拍手]
tan
ハンドとりあえずこの開始でこのしてわかったことは頭がめちゃくちゃ痛いですよ時期
がその改正が多いからな間のは揺れて膿栓とみたいになってですが吐き気と頭痛が
すごいですあと300たい
頑張っていきましょうやっぱ今日サブは服装見せた700回までいった日きょう中に
あと200回やって900回までいこうと思いますでは
[音楽]
はぁ
はいちょっと雨がひどいんですけどこのまま続けて
900回まで行っちゃいますでは
[拍手]
[音楽]
850回はできたんですけど近所のお兄さんから差し入れで温かいのようなをもらい
ました
ありがたしまず+金はす今日はと50回が終わります
[音楽]
と呼べる900回終わりましたあと100回前回のでラスト100回頑張っていこうと
思います人もメンタルがポロポロ州では
ああああああ
1月1日でございます今900回お参りしたのでこのシーン年1月1日で黒子に
シャッター異物を終わらせて最高の1年を着ればいいかなと思っております
あと100系
がんばるぞぃ大久保まで来ると寒くないしもう僕は900回の前でを通して不屈の心を
手に入れたので大企業は関係ありませんやっていきましょう
[音楽]
[拍手]
ni
[音楽]
[拍手]
快適で皆さん明けましておめでとうございます改めて基世津翁です
旋回を前に本当につらかったです
6着背負い頑張ってな月発行良さそうに見えるんですけど絶対マネしないで下さい何ず
に100かいのペースにしてからお参りしたあと一問
頭痛と吐き気で寝込んでましたお辞儀のしすぎで凄いのぉ立ダメージを与えてしまった
んで皆さん絶対真似しないようにしてくださいで実際旋回を前にしたこの僕のうん
なんですけど今年一発目にもう今年1発目どんなもんかだと思ってあのコンビニで一番
くじ引いたんですよ一番くじ引いてみたところ
一番いい詠唱が2個出ましたん
me
ああああああ
あっはぁ